foreign
wanted to compare him to Donald Trump
but poor old Donald Trump wishes he
looked like Silvio Berlusconi we could
say that Berlusconi started from nothing
and conquered absolute power like almost
no one else in history he not only
conquered political power in Italy he
also amassed business power and Media
power if power corrupts absolute power
corrupts absolutely and bernosconi's
life has many Shadows but also many
highlights to begin with there is
something that we have to recognize
about this man and it is something that
frankly is enviable his energy think
about it Berlusconi died on the 12th of
June at the age of 86. he was an old man
well last year he appeared on Tick Tock
with this video
we're not going to go into what he's
actually saying in the message of this
video but what I want to emphasize here
is that the man you just saw was an 85
year old man when this recording was
made when he was running again in an
election in which he had a real chance
of winning I don't know about you but I
wish I could reach the age of 85 with
that kind of energy that said are we
going to praise Berlusconi in this video
of course no
to speak of Berlusconi is to speak of
corruption tailor-made laws and a
political Legacy that is mediocre to say
the least we could say that a good
number of the problems that Italy
suffers from and there are not of just a
few of them are his fault I suppose that
most of the obituaries you read out
there will also mention berlusconi's
many sex scandals and his bunga bunga
parties we're going to leave all that
aside because we're going to focus on
two things the political and business
profile of this man and believe me these
two aspects alone would be enough to
make a movie in fact there is already a
Berlusconi biopic and it is a
masterpiece Loro by Paulo Sorrentino
highly recommended for better or worse
Berlusconi has defined what Italy is
today but not only that he also brought
about a revolution in the media
throughout much of Europe said why does
everyone know berlusconi's name what is
his political Legacy why do we say he
has been revolutionary in the business
world today we're going to answer all of
these questions but first let's look at
some history
[Applause]
[Music]
the first difference between Berlusconi
and Donald Trump as their birth well
Trump was born into a family that was
already immensely wealthy Berlusconi was
born into a middle-class family in Milan
normal parents normal education and a
normal life however Berlusconi had
something special he was fascinated by
Show Business and was the best salesman
you could find in fact berlusconi's
Beginnings were as a singer that's right
Berlusconi started his career as a
crooner who entertained parties on
cruise ships in the lake not
surprisingly that also launched his Fame
as a heartthrob but as we said we're not
going to focus on anyone's sex life
because we are a serious Channel no sex
at all fine the fact is that by
entertaining The Beautiful People of
Milan By Night Berlusconi made the
contracts to start his first big
business project Milano Doo a mega
project of 4 000 homes that was an
economic success but make no mistake
what Berlusconi was really interested in
was the not the real estate market but
the media in fact in these early years
of his career we have to recognize one
thing he was a Visionary and we're about
to find out exactly how
The Godfather of private TV
if you are watching this video from
outside Europe you may be surprised but
there was a time when private TV
channels were banned in most of Europe
and no we're not just talking about
Eastern Europe here in the 1970s
television in Italy and other countries
like Spain was a state-owned monopoly
that is if you turned on the TV you only
had the channels of Rai that is the
Italian state-owned television
Corporation to give you an idea in 1973
the Italian government issued a decree
prohibiting any attempt to set up a
private television station in fact they
not only had a monopoly on television
but also on television advertising and
that was a very very lucrative business
Berlusconi was perfectly aware of this
and therefore his goal was to end this
Monopoly in order to have his own
National Television Network the question
is how do you do it well pay attention
because this is a story worthy of a
visual politic video the first question
we have to ask ourselves is why was TV a
monopoly well because of the radio
spectrum
thank you
at that time there was no Digital
television let alone the internet
television was broadcast by radio
frequency and the radio spectrum is
limited in other words there were not
infinite frequencies for anyone who
wants to broadcast TV however around
that time a new technology for
broadcasting television emerged cables
now cables cool cable TV offered enough
space to broadcast multiple TV channels
so what's the problem well not all homes
in Italy were ready to receive it except
for the Mahomes of Milano do that is
[Applause]
exactly Berlusconi arranged for his 4
000 Home Development to have cable TV
after a long legal battle the Italian
constitutional Court allowed the
creation of a private TV stations
broadcasting on cable as long as they
did so only at the local level well
Berlusconi had 4 000 households that
could become viewers of his own
television content and that is how tele
Milano was born a television station
that was super local it was basically a
neighborhood television station of
course tele Milano was not the only
television broadcasting on Cable local
TV guys but it was one of the most
popular because it had 4 000 captive
viewers but wait because this is only
the beginning two years later in 1976
the Constitutional Court ruled again on
the TV issue this time they allowed
private TV stations to broadcast by
radio frequency as long as they were
only local that is you could have a TV
channel in Milan or Torino or Rome but
not a channel broadcasting nationally so
what do you think Berlusconi did at this
point well good old Silvio was dedicated
to buying up all of the local TV
channels in all of the regions of Italy
in a few years he got hold of Roma TV
video Benito tele Torino basically he
managed to get a hold of all the private
TV stations in the country he United
them into Italy's First Media Group in
1981 all these local TV stations changed
their logos to canale 5.
and that is how Berlusconi achieved what
has seemed impossible to end a state
Monopoly now he could compete head to
head with the Rai Empire thanks to
having National TV network Canal A5
could sign the most popular public TV
presenters and pundits this is how the
famous Mike Bongiorno left the
state-owned corporation for his new and
brand new private television Company the
strategy could not have been more
aggressive Berlusconi wanted to storm
the market and for that he spared no
expense he bought the most popular
series in the United States and even
introduced Japanese anime into Italian
homes to give you an idea between 1980
and 1981 alone Canal A5 went from a
turnover of 13 billion Lira to more than
75 billion Lira by 1987 berlusconi's TV
network already had a 48 share of screen
time in the whole country
in case you were not yet astonished
remember that only 15 years earlier
private television stations in Italy
were not allowed by law and this feat we
have to give bearless Goldie credit for
but if you thought that his business
career stops here you are very wrong
after conquering Italy Silvio went on to
conquer Europe and boy or boy did he
conquer Europe thus was born the media
set group a company that remains today
under the name of media for Europe one
of the largest media groups in Europe
foreign
basically this man was dedicated to
buying shares in many of the private
television stations that were beginning
to emerge in other countries around him
and this is where we come to Spain until
1989 private television was also banned
in Spain but in the 1990s the government
put an end to the state Monopoly and
then there was Silvio also known as IL
Cavalier ready to enter with telefenko
and here we come to the darkest part of
berlusconi's business career debt you
don't build such a media Empire in just
over 10 years without borrowing money
from half of the World by 1994 finnavest
which is the financial arm of Silvio's
Empire was the second most indebted
company in all of Italy so at that point
what do you think he did what's the next
step when you become Lord and Master of
the media well you pack up your things
and you leave the company that's right
in 1994 Berlusconi gave up all his
leadership positions however he kept all
the shares in his Empire keep this fact
in mind because it is going to be
important for the next phase of the
story but where did burlesconi go well
we're gonna find out
right now
[Music]
the political Conquest
Italian politics is really crazy it
doesn't matter at which point in time
you're hearing this it applies to any
period in history in this country Prime
Ministers last on average 2.5 years if
you study Italian politics you will find
conspiracies carried out by secret
lodges State terrorism and of course
mafias of all types it was only one
constant Christian democracy we are
talking about a center-right political
party that dominated the country
throughout the Cold War era however in
1994 Christian democracy was dissolved
due to a spiral of corruption scandals
worthy of a Banana Republic the right
was orphaned and the left was not
convincing voters but where there are
people willing to buy there is someone
willing to sell and who knows how to
sell better than anyone else exactly
Silvio Berlusconi during the 1980s he
had publicly supported the Socialist
Party but now he knew that if he wanted
to win elections he had to switch sides
and that's how he created his own
center-right party although the truth is
we could say that it was a party without
ideology basically the process went like
this what do Italians like more than
pizza and women soccer and what do
Italians shout when they support their
Nash national team Forza Italia great
well we already have the name of the
party we're all done here we can go for
an early lunch wait what do you mean
ideology well we're we're for the good
and we're against the bad come on who
wouldn't vote for such a party that's
how in 1994 the year of the World Cup
Berlusconi created Forza Italia
[Music]
to tell you that Berlusconi won the
elections that very same year and why
might you ask well for three reasons
first he had control of the biggest
television station in the country and
believe me that helps second the rest of
the parties were killing each other in
internal disputes and thirdly we are
talking about one of the most
charismatic personalities ever known so
this is how the most impressive
political career in Italian History
began that does not mean that Silvio has
always won the elections remember that
Italian politics is chaos even for him
he has been prime minister in different
interrupted periods now we can say that
Berlusconi has been the politician who
has governed Italy for the longest
period of time in recent history and we
can also say that he has been the prime
minister with the most power because he
not only controlled politics but also
the media to give you an idea according
to estimates by The Economist in 2001 he
came to control 91 of the screen share
of Italian TV think of it this way he
was the owner of canal A5 and at the
same time he dominated State television
conclusion the man who ended the TV
Monopoly in the 1980s ended up building
another Monopoly where have we heard
that before
[Music]
and this is where we come to the darkest
part of his life because if power
corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely and Berlusconi turned
Parliament into his own backyard plain
and simple he passed laws that were
tailor-made for just him for example in
2004 Italy passed a law to give
financial aid for the purchase of
digital TV decoders and who had the main
company that sold these devices exactly
berlusconi's family and this is just one
example in a very long list tax
amnesties Financial regulations we could
say that Silvio changed Italy to make it
fit his interests
but no let's get to the most important
thing of all the general picture what
political outcome does Berlusconi leave
behind apart from corruption has he been
good for the Italians well let's take a
look at that
no
[Music]
power for power's sake
Italy's economy is to put it bluntly
even worse than its political class and
it makes no difference when you are
hearing this actually Italy had a very
good period in the 1980s that is when
Berlusconi was building his business
Empire the country was on fire in the
early 1990s the Italians were richer
than the British and were close to
catching up with the Germans now however
Italy is in Europe's intensive care unit
one of the few countries that is now
poorer than it was 20 years ago and why
you may ask we have a couple of videos
where we explain it in detail one from
visualpolitik and one from our sister
Channel visual economic I'll leave the
link in the description below but here's
a brief summary Italy has systemic
problems that make it almost impossible
for it to function it has a huge and
totally inefficient state with more than
3 million civil servants and a lot of
public spending but that's not all one
of Italy's great weaknesses is the most
absurd bureaucracy you can imagine for
example almost all the perfect sessions
are governed by regulatory colleges that
means if you want to work as a
journalist or as a computer scientist
you need a license and getting that
license is a process that seems to be
from another era
well with all these problems Italy in
the 1980s grew thanks to one thing they
were addicted to devaluation Italy
devalued its currency to make its
products cheaper on the international
market during the 1980s and 1990s made
in Italy was sweeping Europe in the
2000s China joined the World Trade
Organization and Italy joined the Euro
conclusion they could not compete with
the even cheaper prices of Chinese
companies and they could not devalue
their currency either it began a long
crisis from which they have yet to
emerge however Silvio bernasconi only
wanted to win elections so his political
proposal for the goods and against the
bad right I mean what do Italians want
to maintain the illusion that there are
no problems that nothing needs to be
reformed and that things will be fine
maintain public spending while the
economy sinks that is what Berlusconi
has always promised and what Berlusconi
has achieved so what's the flip side of
this policy
[Music]
well you see right now Italy ranks
seventh in the world in debt to GDP and
fifth in debt per capita in fact today
Italy is one of the biggest headaches in
all of Europe and in a way a good part
of that is due to what Berlusconi did or
rather did not do despite having more
power than almost any other politician
and what is Berlusconi done in recent
years well the truth is that he's never
abandoned Politics as we saw at the
beginning of this video even at the age
of 84 he continued to run for election
however we can hardly find any
interesting political positions except
for this one Silvio Berlusconi xpm
defends Russian war on Eve of Italian
election exactly Berlusconi has been
supporting Russia and the Ukrainian War
and why you may ask well his argument
was based on the fact that he knew
Vladimir Putin personally and they were
very good friends in this case it seems
like berlusconi's private life does
affect his political positions or so it
appears from photos like this one
conclusion so no one can deny that
Berlusconi was a true genius a self-made
man he managed to have more power than
almost any other man in history he
combined economic political and Media
power in the same person however he used
all that power in a mediocre way to say
the least and now the questions are over
to you will we ever see a new leader
with as much power centered in one man
as bearlusconi are there other
International leaders we could compare
him with and would you like to reach
80-something years of age with as much
energy as Silvio you can leave me your
answers in the comments below as always
don't forget that here on visualpolitik
we release new videos every single week
so subscribe to this Channel and hit
little bell down there so you don't miss
any of our updates if you like this
video like it so we know all the best I
hope you enjoyed it and I'll see you
next time
[Music]